freunde der sonne letzte woche wurde ein
youtube-video gedroppt und wenn es so
was wie science youtube dann wäre es auf
platz eins
neben solana cache reihe into the us has
any other babys a few weeks ago das ist
zumindest werde ich in so nell in
wirklichkeit heißt also und hat eine
wissenschaftliche premiere für uns er
hat nämlich die ersten menschlichen gen
editierten babys zur welt gebracht also
hat sie nicht selbst zur welt gebracht
das wäre es noch die zwillingstöchter
luana pseudonym übrigens kamen zur welt
die eltern sind grace und mag und mag
ist hiv-positiv geht hier an kury hat
jetzt ihre eizellen und sein sperma
genommen im labor eine künstliche
befruchtung durchgeführt so weit so
normal
jetzt hat dabei aber auch noch china
meldet ihn also eine gezielte
veränderung des erbguts durchgeführt und
zwar so dass die beiden babys sich nicht
mehr mit hiv anstecken können dann hat
er die endlos wieder der mutter
eingepflanzt und diese beiden babys
wurden jetzt geboren
zumindest behauptet das mädchen qi er
ist auf youtube und paar tage später auf
einer großen internationalen konferenz
über die nummer ditting in hongkong
es war einfach so what the [ __ ] is
kritisiert reißen wir uns jetzt alle mal
zusammen und fragen uns was bedeutet das
jetzt
designer baby dystopie oder
medizinischer durchbruch durch inti
freunde der sonne ihr habt fragen und
die klären wie jetzt
[Musik]
ok erst mal vielen dank für eure vielen
fragen und den input
ich habe mir alles durchgelesen und auf
dieser basis zehn fragen und antworten
zusammengestellt die hoffentlich vieles
klarer machen
in der video beschreibung werdet ihr
auch time codes finden wo ihr zu den
einzelnen fragen springen könnt aber
schaut euch lieber alles an also wenn es
um eure gene geht solltet ihr lieber
bescheid wissen fangen wir an mit nummer
eins china um editing genom meditieren
was kann man damit überhaupt machen die
gesamtheit unsere gene nennt man genom
auf englisch chino kann auch einfach
erbgut sagen das genom könnt ihr euch
vorstellen wie eine verschlüsselte
bibliothek jedes gehen besteht aus einer
reihenfolge von buchstaben und in dieser
reihenfolge ist information codiert das
ist ein code für all unsere biologischen
infos sei es jetzt unsere augenfarbe
aber es können auch sachen sein wie
anfälligkeiten für bestimmte krankheiten
so china etc ist quasi text editing
textbearbeitung für die gene
man kann jetzt ausnahmen gehen
buchstaben raus löschen und neu
reinschreiben man kann den code neu
schreiben was medizinisch ganz schön
viel versprechend sein kann wenn man zum
beispiel aus krank gesund machen kann
wenn man in weiß in welche buchstaben
sequenz eine bestimmte krankheit steckt
wahrscheinlich habt ihr aber auch schon
von christa oder chris beckers nein
gehört das ist eine neue regierung
editing methode die einfacher schneller
präziser ist als die bisherigen methoden
und deswegen derzeit die genom editing
methode ist das heißt wenn ich jetzt im
laufe des videos über genom editieren
spreche werde ich manchmal der
einfachheit halber crisp ansagen und ihr
wisst was gemeint ist so das menschliche
genom besteht aus zehntausenden geben
und jedes gehen besteht aus zehn bis
hundert tausenden oder noch mehr
buchstaben das heißt wenn man jetzt ein
paar buchstaben hier raus verändert oder
löscht dann ist das ganze immer noch zum
beispiel ein mensch wir schaffen mit
chris weitz keine neuen spezies und ich
kann mir jetzt auch nicht irgendwie
finger oder einhorn auf die stirn oder
superkräfte krispl zweitens welches
gehen wurde bei den beiden babys
verändert und warum das gen heißt tc 5
und in ihm sind informationen über unser
immunsystem codiert so bei zehn prozent
der europäer und amerikaner fielen in
diesem ccr5 gehen 32 buchstaben die
haben also eine mutation von diesem ccr5
gehen ein prozent der menschen erben
diese mutation von beiden eltern also
von mutter und vater
und diese menschen sind so ziemlich
immun gegen hiv und angeblich wurde
genau diese mutation im rahmen dieser
künstlichen befruchtung rein editiert
bei diesen zwillingen bei einem der
babys beide kopien bei dem anderen baby
nur eine
drittens gibt es nebenwirkungen ja
fußball ist keine perfekte methode es
kann zum beispiel sogenannte off target
effekte geben das heißt dass andere gene
außer des gewünschten gehens verändert
werden es kann on target effekte geben
das ist wenn an den gehen verschiedene
veränderungen auftreten nicht nur die
gewünschte es kann zu einem mosaik
effekt führen wenn zum beispiel in
meinem körper wo jede zelle eigentlich
dasselbe genom tragen müsste
verschiedene zellen verschiedene gene
tragen um zu schauen ob alles gut
gegangen ist müsste man das genom
sequenzieren also vollständig
aufschlüsseln und dann die buchstaben
reihenfolge überprüfen ob auch wirklich
alles so gelaufen ist wie man sich
vorgestellt hat angeblich ist bei den
zwillingen alles gut gelaufen aber diese
wissenschaftlichen daten die wurden
bisher noch nicht verifiziert
außerdem tat ein und dasselbe gehen
verschiedene auswirkungen auf unsere
biologie haben das cch 5 gehen hat nicht
nur auswirkungen auf hiv infektionen
sondern kann die infektionsgefahr für
andere virusinfektionen sogar erhöhen
zum beispiel für die krippe oder den
west nil virus viertens wie groß ist der
medizinische gewinn
ich sage es einfach nicht so groß im
vergleich zu den risiken erst mal ging
es hier nicht um das behandeln einer
tödlichen oder bisher unheilbaren
krankheit sondern um das vorbeugen einer
behandelbaren krankheit es gibt neben
jean um editing andere wirksame methoden
um sich gegen hiv zu schützen
es ist nicht so dass wir es hier mit
einem medizinischen problem zu tun haben
für das es bisher keine andere lösung ab
und via pfosten meisten ländern immer
noch und verbreitetes problem
und er steht jetzt seine arbeit da als
lösung dieses problems als eine art
genetisches impfen
der vergleich mit impfen ist ziemlich
weit hergeholt vor allem was die
machbarkeit betrifft weil man muss hier
für eine erfolgreiche künstliche
befruchtung und eine erfolgreiche
schwangerschaft von alles schaffen und
erfolgreiches china metting ohne die
nebenwirkungen die wir gerade genannt
haben
und das ist das kann man als therapie
für einen einzelnen vielleicht angehen
aber das ist sicherlich keine lösung für
ganze population 5
wie groß ist der medizinische gewinn für
die individuen also für die eltern und
die zwillinge die mutter grace ist hiv
negativ der vater mag es hiv positiv
wenn du ein hiv-positiver vater bist
dann besteht die gefahr dass du dein
kind bei der zeugung über das sperma
infizieren kannst ich selber fahre
riesen riesendruck also fahrer auf
doping aktiv mobil haus sein wird das
ist ja die den gegner kraft als chance
dass stada nominiert ok ich empfinde das
als grenzwertig manipulativ denn bei
einer künstlichen befruchtung kann man
das hiv virus aus dem sperma abwaschen
bevor man mit dem sperma die eizelle
befruchtet das bedeutet china um editing
ist jetzt hier erstmal gar nicht nötig
um die infektionsgefahr bei der zeugung
auszuschalten also ich finde diese
unterscheidung sehr wichtig es geht hier
nur um die die vorbeugung ja dass diese
kinder sich später im leben nicht mit
dem virus infizieren
ob der vater hier zwei vor positiv ist
spielt bei dieser künstlichen
befruchtung erst mal gar keine rolle
aber es spielt natürlich eine rolle für
das recruiting der paare
denn was hier angeblich passiert ist das
beinhaltet eine kostenlose künstliche
befruchtung die normalerweise sehr teuer
ist und noch eine finanzielle
entschädigung drauf und das allein ist
schon ein großes problem denn dieses
paar das hat wahrscheinlich einen
starken wunsch nach einem gesunden kind
und das kann dazu führen dass sie nicht
dazu in der lage sind sachlich risiken
und nutzen abzuwägen sechs können die
chris pratt gene vererbt werden ja in
china meldet ihn wird jetzt schon länger
geforscht aber falls das jetzt alles
stimmt dann wurde hier zum ersten mal in
die keimbahn eingegriffen
das bedeutet dass diese gegend
veränderungen auch vererbt werden können
ganz normal
das neue ist nicht das jetzt hier die
nummer an embryos durchgeführt wurde
das wird schon seinerzeit an gemacht
allerdings an sogenannten in vitro
embryos das sind nonnweiler embryos
nicht lebensfähige die im labor
entstehen durch eine künstliche
befruchtung einer eizelle durch sperma
jetzt wurden aber angeblich zum ersten
mal solche embryos in den mutterleib
eingesetzt sind dort herangewachsen und
kamen zur welt
und wenn diese kinder irgendwann selber
kinder zeugen können sie diese
veränderten gene ganz normal vererben 17
warum ist dieser eingriff in die
keimbahn so heikel wenn man jetzt
irgendwas verkappte irgendwelche
nebenwirkungen auftreten die dann noch
vererbt werden dann hat man natürlich
viel mehr verkannt als wenn nur ein
einzelner mensch betroffen ist man
sollte also verdammt nochmal fucking
sicher sein bevor man in die keimbahn
eingreift und diese sicherheit die gab
es hier nicht außerdem geschieht so ein
jet hin natürlich ohne den content ohne
die zustimmung dieser babys wenn diese
babys jetzt wirklich gekümmert geboren
wurden dann hatten sie niemals die
chance über ihren eigenen körper zu
entscheiden
und selbst risiken und nutzen abzuwägen
und das ist ziemlich abgefuckt das
berühmte an dieser meldung also nicht
dass sie etwas geschafft wurde was
bisher technisch nicht möglich war denn
das war's es ist eher so dass bisher
niemand
die uefa knez besessen hatte das in die
praxis umzusetzen 8 es besteht grund zur
panik prinzipiell schon mal nein denn
panik ist die lösung aber vor allem
haben wir derzeit keine ahnung ob wies
behauptungen stimmen wir wissen weder ob
das ganze wirklich so passiert ist und
falls ja ob das ganze erfolgreich war
die wissenschaftlichen daten sind bisher
noch nicht verifiziert und
veröffentlicht wir haben hier völlige
intransparenz was für wissenschaft ein
absolutes no go ist diese diese
wissenschaft hier bauen wir einfach so
zu droppen ohne verifizierbare evidenz
das geht nicht wie es streng sind ist
das keine wissenschaft alles was es
bisher ist das sind gerüchte
george church von harvard university das
ist einer der genetiker hat gesagt dass
er die daten gesehen hat und dass er es
für wahrscheinlich hält dass es so
passiert ist
aber das hilft ja alles nichts wir
können momentan nur spekulieren und wir
müssen immer sagen falls das passiert
ist dann verstehe ich mich direkt an
einem foto intransparenz was sagt die
wissenschaftliche community dazu rund
120 chinesische wissenschaftler ein
öffentliches statement unterschrieben in
dem sie seine experimente aufs schärfste
verurteilen
seine uni hat sich von ihm distanziert
betont dass sie von den experimenten
nichts wusste und dass er seit januar
2018 freigestellt war internationale
kollegen also alle expertinnen und
experten auf diesem gebiet beurteilen
das ganze als als vorschnell als naiv
als unreflektiert als unverantwortlich
es wird wahrscheinlich auch rechtliche
konsequenzen haben
er musste seine forschung jetzt auch
schon einstellen und die chinesischen
behörden haben untersuchungen gegen ihn
eingeleitet also nur dass das auch klar
ist ja
diakonie vertritt jetzt nicht die
chinesische wissenschaft und auch sonst
keine wissenschaftliche bewegung sondern
steht derzeit so ziemlich allein auf
weiter flur und 10
das habt ihr auch oft gefragt was sage
ich dazu für die diskussion die wir
jetzt darüber führen müssen
ist es eigentlich egal ob das ganze
jetzt stimmt oder nicht den fakt ist es
ist technisch möglich und wenn es jetzt
nicht passiert es dann passiert es dann
nochmal deswegen sollten wir ethisch
juristisch und politisch dafür gewappnet
sein damit wir nicht von der
wissenschaft überrollt werden und dann
irgendwann einfach nur what the [ __ ] is
kritisiert caspar ist ein scharfes
zweischneidiges messer mit dem man
lebensrettende operationen durchführen
kann und menschen töten kann
doch vor allem ist eines wichtig das
menschliche genom gehört uns allen
das ist jetzt kein bereich in dem
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
allein entscheiden sollen und deswegen
ist gut dass ihr euch informiert damit
ihr mitreden könnte und egal ob er für
oder gegen gentechnik seit diese technik
wird kommen und meinetwegen kann sich
auch deutschland dagegen sträuben dann
wird halt der rest der welt ohne uns
mitmachen und uns damit zwangsläufig mit
reinziehen nummer 11 an euch was denkt
ihr schreibt es in die kommentare und
wie es ihnen uns in der endphase folgt
das passiert
[Musik]
beide partner webvideo preis bekommen
und kritisiert offensichtlich ist 2018
das preis ja für meile aber jetzt hier
bei myvideo preis habe ich wirklich
wirklich nicht damit gerechnet womit
krasse konkurrenz alle in derselben
kategorie quasi es gab möglichkeiten und
es waren voting preis und so erscheint
habt ihr einfach abgestimmt danke
ansonsten schauen wir mal ob sich montag
als upload tag durchsetzt wir sehen uns
also nächsten montag bis dahin bleibt
sicher